ah
esta conferencia en realidad la comencé
a preparar hace 30 años
hace 30 años el bosque amazónico fijaba
el doble de carbono de lo que lo hace en
la actualidad hace 30 años el hielo del
ártico ocupaba el doble que en la
actualidad
hace 30 años el nivel del mar subía unos
pocos milímetros al año ahora sube
algunos centímetros al año hace unos 30
años tuvo lugar en río de janeiro una
cumbre histórica la cumbre de la tierra
la primera vez que se ponían juntos más
de 1700 especialistas y representantes
de muchos países y en total unas 100.000
personas estuvieron implicadas en este
evento que sembró las bases para un
montón de programas nacionales e
internacionales y que inspiró programas
de conservación a todas las escalas
cuando esta cumbre tenía lugar yo andaba
por el mundo con unas zapatillas de este
estilo era unas zapatillas genéricas que
lo mismo me servían para jugar al tenis
que para montar en bicicleta que para
pasear con esas zapatillas y estudiaba
biología iba aprendiendo cosas
fascinantes sobre la vida me di cuenta
como muchos ya se habrían dado cuenta y
como muchos siguen sorprendiendo sé de
que la vida pende de un hilo la vida ha
aprendido siempre de un hilo y siempre
dependerá de un hilo
porque la vida es algo realmente
sorprendente porque viene de una
concatenación irrepetible de eventos
entre esos eventos han jugado un papel
muy importante
las colisiones
las colisiones han abierto oportunidades
las colisiones nos vienen a la mente en
seguida algunas realmente gigantes
podríamos pensar
el sistema solar hace 2.200 millones de
años cuando la tierra era muy joven y
compartía la órbita con un planeta
hermano del tamaño de marte como dos
hermanos que comparten habitación
aquello iba a quedar mal y tarde o
temprano pasaría algo y efectivamente
nos pegamos la gran torta de aquí de que
la inmensa colisión el planeta pasó de
girar vertical a girar inclinado quedó
tumbado unos 23 grados y aquella
inclinación abrió una inmensa
oportunidad porque creó el invierno y el
verano muchas zonas de la tierra podían
permanecer a partir de entonces muchos
meses al año libres de hielo pero además
no sólo ocurrió aquello sino del origen
de aquella colisión surgió nuestro
satélite la luna y la luna a su vez
trajo las mareas y las mareas sonaron
nuestro planeta y lo convirtieron un
planeta mucho más habitable pasando un
día de cinco horas frenético al día
actual que conocemos de 24 horas las
colisiones abren muchas oportunidades
pasado un tiempo yo seguía estudiando
con fascinación estas y muchas otras
cosas como biólogo que empezaba
y me di cuenta de que tenía el
colesterol por las nubes era resultado
de que pasaba demasiadas horas en la
biblioteca que pasaba demasiadas horas
delante de ese maldito ordenador y
decidí tomar cartas en el asunto empecé
tímidamente a cambiar de rumbo y compré
unas zapatillas parecidas a esta y me
tomé bastante más en serio aquello de
correr
me sorprendió lo que éramos capaces de
hacer nuestra especie tan pronto
alucinábamos como tan pronto aluniza
vamos de hecho en un mismo planeta en un
mismo país en una orilla se ensayaban
los efectos alucinógenos de una droga y
en la otra orilla se ponía a todos los
esfuerzos para que alguno de nosotros
pisara precisamente ese planeta ese
satélite que nos frenó en algún momento
a la humanidad hacía cada vez cosas más
sorprendentes yo no paraba de alucinar
con los alunizajes y de alucinar con
todas las cosas que éramos capaces de
hacer y un día de pronto la humanidad
hizo la mayor obra hidráulica de la que
hemos sido capaces de hacer construimos
esto esto es la presa de las tres
gargantas en china y aparte de darle
agua a mucha gente y de generar unas
cantidades astronómicas de electricidad
implica un montón de peso en una zona
muy concreta de la tierra que hace que
cambia el centro de gravedad y lo
inclinamos el eje de la tierra no tanto
como el planeta con el que tuvimos
aquella colación pero indudablemente el
efecto era significativo era inferior a
un grado pero lo pudimos medir esa presa
cambio el eje
inclinación de la tierra y en esos años
nos convertimos en la causa de la
tercera parte de los terremotos y
temblores que tienen lugar cada año en
el planeta y además nos convertimos en
agentes geomorfológicos de primer orden
movíamos más cantidad de material que
cualquier agente natural
por su cuenta no
éramos capaces de llenar el mar de
plásticos hacíamos cosas sorprendentes
realmente en aquel entonces yo no paraba
de sorprender pero te de las cosas que
ya se estaba gestando que ya se vio en
la cumbre de río que todos íbamos viendo
era que estábamos volviendo loco al
ciclo del carbono a base de quemar
tantos combustibles fósiles estábamos
llenando en la atmósfera de unos gases
que atrapaban el calor del sol y no lo
soltaban a la velocidad que normalmente
la soltamos pero el ciclo del carbono lo
enloquecimos como esas cosas que hacemos
sin querer ese ciclo del carbono lo
alteramos solamente en la parte de la
atmósfera no éramos capaces de captar
ese carbono a la misma velocidad a la
que lo libera vamos a la atmósfera
precisamente lo que me empezó a resultar
más sorprendente no era es lo que
hacíamos era cómo lo hacíamos como un
niño pequeño travieso que viene con las
manos llenas de pintura y dice lo siento
lo siento perdón pero pero ha sido sin
querer nosotros habíamos cambiado el eje
de inclinación de la tierra nos habíamos
convertido en el principal agente
geomorfológico habíamos hecho del clima
algo preocupante lo estábamos cambiando
una velocidad como nunca se había
cambiado y todo eso sin querer realmente
nos lo teníamos que hacer mirar pasados
unos años hace aproximadamente diez años
nos dimos cuenta muchos que algunas
cosas no funcionaban yo empecé a
intentar relacionar mi afición por las
montañas con mi ejercicio físico y
empecé a probar cosas y os debo confesar
que aprendí cosas divertidas pero
también algunas no funcionaron probé
estas zapatillas fantásticas estas estas
zapatillas son como un guante te las
pones en los pies y es como si corridas
directamente descalzo con estas
zapatillas disfruté mucho pero estas
zapatillas no permiten correr por las
montañas que era mi objetivo
ahí fracasé no se puede correr con un
pie tan descubierto en una zona tan
adversa como esta montaña y desde el 1
lo puedes hacer durante muchas horas
al igual que yo constataba ese error las
naciones unidas- fallaban con su
fastuoso programa de los objetivos del
milenio a pesar del nombre el programa
no cambió grandes cosas falló
nos estábamos dando cuenta de que era
completamente incompatible disfrutar
tanto de estas zapatillas con correr por
montaña y también era incompatible
seguir quemando tantos combustibles
fósiles y mantener las condiciones en el
planeta en la biosfera en los
ecosistemas que son precisamente
necesarias para nosotros entrábamos en
un rumbo de colisión con nosotros mismos
había que darse cuenta de que las cosas
no iban bien
pero esa atmósfera que estábamos
calentando sin querer no sólo generaba
huracanes más intensos gotas frías más
intensas no sólo generaba frío cuando
hace calor olas de calor cuando hace
frío y sequías tremendas estaba
impactando directamente sobre nosotros
el cambio climático mata a más de
200.000 personas cada año el cambio
climático provoca que 160 millones de
personas hagan migraciones a larga
distancia cada año exponemos unos muros
unas vallas a veces les facilitamos la
vida con un barco o con un camión pero
es sin lugar a dudas una fuente de
conflicto que tenemos delante de las
narices
el cambio climático provoca conflictos
bélicos tensiones económicas y todo tipo
de problemas
es hora yo creo de cambiar de rumbo no
podemos seguir así yo creo que lo
llevábamos sabiendo hacía bastante
tiempo pero empieza a ver cierta
urgencia para cambiar de rumbo hacen
falta básicamente dos cosas por un lado
hace falta convicción
pero no basta con la convicción hace
falta de más motivación me recuerda al
ejercicio que estoy hoy poniendo como
analogía y que a mí me ha servido
personalmente como una fuente de
motivación y de estímulo el ejercicio
todos sabemos que hace falta hacer
ejercicio que es muy saludable hacer
ejercicio que no suele faltar motivación
para hacerlo de manera regular
mi propuesta hoy es que podemos
encontrar fuentes de motivación lo iré
ilustrando de alguna manera
pero permitidme que haga una pequeña
reflexión yo cuando cambie de rumbo
cuando fue cambiando de zapatillas llegó
un momento que me adapte a las que llevo
puestas que son unas zapatillas
realmente pensadas para la montaña que
te protegen el pie y te permiten trepar
mientras hacía todo eso mi cuerpo lo
sometía a una transformación profunda el
cambio de rumbo trajo un montón de
novedades novedades fisiológicas
anatómicas no sólo perdía algunos kilos
sino transforme la grasa en músculo mi
corazón se convirtió en otra cosa tenía
otros latidos otras intensidades el
sistema circulatorio cambió
profundamente mixtas a saddam
enzimáticas metabólicas y esas
transformaciones profundas me
permitieron algo tan sencillo y tan
maravilloso como es subir corriendo a la
cima de una montaña
un día estábamos hablando con mi
entrenadora planeando una carrera y me
decía ella además es buena nutricionista
me dijo fernando tienes un perfil
lipoproteína desastroso si fueras obeso
sedentario y fumador ya con sus 54 años
habrías tenido más de un accidente
cardiovascular pero aquello me dejó un
poquito pensativo
probablemente no hubiera hecho falta que
yo me hubiera lanzado a las carreras de
ultra montaña no me hubiera hecho falta
pero desde luego me lancé hice el cambio
y sufrí una serie de transformaciones
que me abrieron un montón de
oportunidades esa novedad que fui
disfrutando me permitió nunca lo sabría
yo
y llegar a salvar incluso mi vida a
compensar por mi genética defectuosa y
por mis hábitos sedentarios
nos acercamos al presente nos acercamos
con cierta ansiedad las naciones unidas
vuelven a lanzar otro programa hace unos
diez años las naciones unidas- que
estaban mientras yo avanzaban mis
progresos lanzaban otro otro ambicioso
programa este programa el desarrollo
sostenible era diferente se habían
aprendido de los errores yo aprendí de
mis zapatillas algunas de ellas no
funcionaban no eran lo suficientemente
aptas para lo que me proponía las
naciones unidas- intentaban no dejar a
nadie atrás en esta agenda y nos
ilusionaba con objetivos muy diversos
muy transversal es muy inclusivos que
nos hacían reflexionar sobre quién debe
liderar el cambio mi idea es que la
propia agenda es un objetivo en sí mismo
la idea la noción de que podemos cambiar
cosas debe ser la motivación cuando
empecé a preparar esta charla hace 30
años la conservación de la naturaleza se
hacía
por todo tipo de razones pero sin la
gente se hacía por cuestiones éticas
morales religiosas espirituales por la
responsabilidad que tendríamos con
nuestras siguientes generaciones y eso
no funcionó años después la conservación
pasó a hacerse para la gente y se
hablaba de servicios y bienes
ecosistémicos le sacábamos el jugo a los
ecosistemas y la naturaleza estaba a
nuestro servicio debíamos conservarla
porque estaba para nosotros pasamos del
sinn al para y ahora tenemos que pasar
todavía a otra más a otra fase en la que
sea conservación con la gente somos arte
y parte de lo que le pasa a la
naturaleza y no nos vale en seguir
explotándola porque trae allá a la
naturaleza a la biosfera a los
ecosistemas les da igual lo que nos pase
a nosotros es a nosotros las que nos da
igual lo que le pase a ella en esto
tenemos que empezar a pensar diferente
tenemos que evitar actos de vandalismo
global como que se prenda fuego a un
bosque tropical las figuras de
protección de espacios naturales
protegidos
las sanciones nacionales e
internacionales claramente no son
eficientes
no son suficientes lo estamos viendo hay
que pensar diferente tenemos que cambiar
nuestra relación con el planeta el
planeta no nos necesita nosotros les
necesitamos a él necesitamos la biosfera
en determinadas condiciones para poder
estar vivos
cuál es la motivación dónde vamos a
encontrar la motivación el miedo no
bastan las pequeñas acciones
individuales de reciclar de ir más en
bicicleta son bien intencionadas van en
la buena dirección pero tampoco bastan
tenemos que hacer un cambio mucho más
profundo y tendremos que hacerlo
nosotros no podemos esperar nada de los
políticos no se ponen de acuerdo lo más
sencillo tenemos que empujar también a
los políticos tiene que ser un cambio
colectivo y profundo decidido audaz y
donde encontraremos la motivación para
hacerlo la podemos encontrar por ejemplo
en reconocer que tenemos el derecho
todos y cada uno de ser parte de ese
cambio tan necesario en la biosfera
necesita otra mirada y una manera de
hacer explícita esta nueva relación que
podemos establecer a partir de hoy con
el planeta es reconocer a la biosfera a
las componentes intrínsecos de la
biosfera entidad jurídica sus derechos
propios la naturaleza no está a nuestro
servicio tiene sus propios derechos no
son nuestros derechos son sus derechos
en este reconocimiento de la biosfera y
de la naturaleza como entidad jurídica
con derechos propios no empezamos de
cero ya tenemos buenos ejemplos hay
jurisprudencia ecuador reconoce derechos
propios a la naturaleza tres ríos entre
rincones del planeta súper diferentes
completamente distintos
ya son reconocidos como entidad jurídica
el wan gang wi en nueva zelanda el
ganges en la india el atrato en colombia
tres ríos tres situaciones tres
continentes ya tienen entidad jurídica
eso es un buen ejemplo de pensar
diferente y de ahí en adelante cuando yo
comencé a prepararme esta charla
realmente nunca pensé lo que le
llegaríamos a hacer al planeta no pude
imaginarme lo cuando yo empecé a
prepararme esta charla las cosas eran
diferentes también es verdad que yo era
muy diferente en aquel entonces
un biólogo estaba descubriendo muchas
cosas que ahora son solo apreciables en
los museos no tenemos otros 30 años para
preparar otra charla como esta tenemos
apenas 10 para poner realmente en marcha
un cambio de rumbo que evite la colisión
con nosotros mismos
hoy quiero creer que seremos capaces de
hacer ese rumbo y encontraremos la
motivación para hacerlo porque vosotros
como yo queremos seguir corriendo y
recorriendo este magnífico planeta
durante muchos años y se nos consta y
sabemos bien seguro que nadie puede
hacer este viaje por sí mismo y solo
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]